non
tu n'es pas une vitesse
à venir monsieur
tu n'es pas un nouveau parfum
sur moi
c'est lequel de ces TDI
de loi des
retenu pour être indispicker
on crie de mon de bien que Dieu
croyez-moi
comme nous on dit cap n'est pas une
chose mais une Charde pour la société
le monde
il retire mon mieux
sur moi
depuis 5 ans
la société
me donne
depuis 18 ans c'est la lecture
avec les retraites
avant vous
et oui qui veut devenir handicapé
[Musique]
un peu donné
et
ça va pas tarder mais comme il me reste
près des minutes
je pense que si on m'a devait
demander de venir
c'est pour dire quelque chose
tu n'es pas pour rien
en effet
de la volonté
père
et marié et diète repère Manon du Dieu
[Musique]
la vie est belle
de Frank Capra
un célèbre film qui a eu tiens
Oscar
de 1946
qui connaît
ok
à tout le monde s'avenir mais au début
c'est
le lève la main il y en aura d'autres ou
pas par
envie d'être de premier bon
ceux qui connaissent ce film vous savez
un peu que
Dior le Bellay avait été confronté à des
dettes monumentale
de la faillite
[Musique]
et à ce moment là
il rencontre son nom
Clarins
qui lui montre
que c'est une habille aurait été sur lui
une catastrophe
dramatique pire de vie Didier
financière et même
plusieurs personnes de son entourage
serait morte
quel est le rapport avec moi
avec vous
avec nous
[Musique]
que je peux bouger
c'est que si vous êtes la seule fois
ici et maintenant
ce n'est pas pour rien
nous aimerions bien
vivre
à une autre
partie pour regarder si
c'est du nouveau
aller
dévier le cours des choses où la
meilleure
mais c'est une erreur
si on est là
c'est pas pour rien
à travers
[Musique]
la dernière
monnaie de trouver
et avec un handicap c'est génial
nous vivons une une période formidable
d'ailleurs
si j'avais vécu à un autre moment
[Musique]
une erreur médicale depuis ma naissance
dû à une erreur
et les progrès de la médecine en vidéo
et un miroir
et donnons d'éclairer moi-même
quelqu'un de vous comme un projecteur
le miroir du handicap
vouliez dire rassurez-vous
celui-là comme la reine dans
Blanche-Neige
tu auras fortement
vous répond
oui
c'est toi
la plus belle
si vous la plus belle
par rapport à moi
il n'y a pas photo
le vieux porte sur moi
l'erreur médicale une
erreur
nous on dit Gap
c'est une erreur de la nature
horrible de dire
et souvent
vu ma gueule
et on a pas de ME contre
[Musique]
le processus
l'homme dit le handicap
interrogue sur nos erreurs
les plus
pour nous il y a peu gentil
pour nous
pousser à la dépression
où est-ce qu'il dit nous pouvons
ouvrira autre chose
c'est s'ouvrira autre chose mais pour
qu'il y a il faut
de mon
identité profonde
je fuis
[Musique]
on m'ouvrant
a été quelque chose
de plus grand que moi
pour réussir à vivre
avec un handicap
nous sommes un budget à demander de
l'aide
à la bonne personne et au bon moment
il est de nous l'avons besoin
je n'ai pas d'autre
qui est capable de discerner
cette aide
c'est la personne
elle-même qui peut le faire
en couvrant à l'autre
que du moi
ne pouvait passer au choix
à tes deux jours de plus grand
d'ailleurs
on peut s'y connu
car
[Musique]
je crois
et des hommes le soleil
qui éclairé la terre
avez-vous déjà vu le système solaire de
cette façon
peut-être pas
on est trop long d'abord uniquement les
planètes tourner autour du Soleil
[Musique]
aussi dans l'univers
ité même
à une vitesse
de
40 km
par
j'ai pris le TGV sur ma gueule dans les
crocodiles
[Musique]
on va vite et on dit d'une moule de plus
en public
vous voyez le choix c'est vraiment
le lieu du centre de notre vie
et avec le moi
on ne peut que
préparer
l'ouverture au choix
d'ailleurs
est-ce
que j'ai des prix
à pour tous mes examens
est-ce que je suis prêt
j'ai été pris pour me marier
pour
pour me aider
je suis prêt pour être hors de elles
étaient pris pour être ordonné d'y être
berneur
et pour
de me dire ouvert
au choix
ainsi soit-il
[Applaudissements]